Speaker 1: They are now officially moving on to
gay marriage. We said as we approached and learned
about and then got beyond the Supreme Court
decision overturning Roe v Wade, that they are not
ending with overturning Roe v Wade. And why would
they? You don't get your biggest win and then say,
now we retire. We don't want anything
else. Clarence Thomas, in his opinion
and others, have said, we've got to go
on to gay marriage, we've got to go on to
gay adoption, let's ban abortion outright, all of
these different things. And Ted Cruz is now moving
on and he is one of many who are now focusing
on this. Ted Cruz on his podcast is now saying
the issue of gay marriage should also be left
to states. Now, what does that mean? That
means states should be able to ban gay marriage.
That's what you that's what you mean when you say
it should be decided by the
states. Listen to Ted Cruz.
Speaker 2: Obergefell, like Roe versus Wade,
ignored two centuries of our nation's history.
Marriage was always an issue that was left to
the states. In Obergefell, the court said, No,
we know better than you guys do. And now every
state must must sanction and permit gay marriage.
I think that decision was clearly wrong when
it was decided it was the court overreaching.
Speaker 1: Imagine that. Applied
to interracial marriage. Listen,
it's not that I'm against interracial marriage.
It's that the Supreme Court cannot decide that
for the states. States must be allowed to
determine do they want to allow interracial
marriages or not? That's the right way to do it.
And if you extrapolate out from this idea of leave
everything to the states, black folks might still
be enslaved in some states in the South. I mean,
maybe not today, but certainly into
the early 1900s. That's for damn sure.
Civil rights and liberties are not states
rights issues. They are guaranteed by the
Constitution. You don't put rights up to a
vote at this point. Most Americans recognize
that when you tell one person that they are
able to get married and someone else that they
can't marry, the person that they love, you are
depriving you are depriving them of something that
most Americans now recognize is a right. You just
you can marry the person that you love. We're not
talking about marrying horses. We're not talking
about marrying vehicles. We're talking about two
people entering into a contract that they want to
enter into. You just don't put that up to a vote.
And if you said to them, by the way, well,
let states regulate guns however they want.
They would say, no, no, no, no, no. We need the
Supreme Court to tell states you can't do that
because of the Second Amendment. And in fact,
the Supreme Court recently did do that with a
case that got to the Supreme Court related to
guns. So this is obviously their next target.
They're not hiding it. They're being clear they
won't stop here and they're going to keep going.
And this is as as demoralizing as it has
been to see what happened with Roe v Wade.
If we now say we're bailing out on the political
system, it will go to the next thing. It will go
to gay marriage or whatever else, because they're
they're inspired, they're activated. They're fired
up now. So it puts 2022 really in focus, as I
would argue, the most important midterm election
I've covered during the time I've been doing
the show. If you disagree with me, let me know.
Let me put it a different way. Has there been
a more important midterm election? I would even
say since 1994, when Gingrich and that wacky
Republican coalition took power. Tell me,
I want to know, has there been a more important
midterm than the one that is forthcoming?